Oh,
the transhumanist would respond to that.
You're just used to this idea of only
living 80,
90 years and then you're done.
Uh,
that we would adjust to that.
Well,
maybe
the other question would be who would be
the weed that would adjust to that?
Yes.
You would no longer okay to get there.
We would really no longer be human
there.
The idea of the transhumanist and
singularitarian people is,
is truly,
you're not human anymore.
We have brain,
like the cochlear implant for hearing is
a kind of brain transplant device.
Well,
they want to ramp that up and put chips
in your cortex and you'd hit said
essentially have Wikipedia in your
brain.
It's for instant access and so and,
and so it,
it would truly bring new meaning to what
it means to be human.
Right.
You could also argue that that's a form
of death because if you transform
yourself,
so without it,
you're unrecognizable.
Then what?
Where's the continuity with what you
once were?
You know,
this is one of the reasons I have some
real sympathy for many reasons.
I have many reasons for this,
but one of them that I have very much
sympathy for.
The idea,
the Christian idea that's that's
associated with the mortality of the
resurrection of the body because the
Christians insisted that this is not
some sort of abstract life like it's,
it's not uploaded into a computer.
It's not blowing out all of your
limitations.
Now,
you know,
you might ask what the resurrected body
would be and of course that's a
particularly,
that's a perfectly fine question,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't.
That doesn't move you around the fact
that there was a question that was
really to be grappled with there because
what the Christians were trying to do
was to have their take and eat it too in
some sense and to say,
look,
there's some out salute utility to the
limitation that's imposed upon you by a
mortal frame.
Right.
That's the characteristic element of
being human and that perhaps there's a
way of having that in transcending it up
at the same time.
Now what that would look like is
obviously by,
right.
I deal with that and Evan's on her to
have a chapter on the soul and you know,
post Descartes,
Christians became more doulas before
that they were more focused on the
physical resurrection of the body.
There are still some Christian sex today
who think that they'll physically be
resurrected but most more of them,
most of them are do list and it's just
your,
it's just this kind of nonphysical thing
that goes and,
and be and is with God and Jesus and so
on.
Uh,
but,
but they actually debate this
question of identity,
the problem with identity because he
say,
well,
if you're physically resurrected in
heaven,
what's,
what's there?
How old are you?
And some of them actually have an
answer.
You're 30.
That's like the ideal age physically I
suppose mentally to be third and also
Jesus was 30
maybe.
Okay.
So,
but,
but then the question is,
is know,
and I ask this question for the mindup
loaders and the transhumanist,
it's like there is no fixed self,
first of all,
all your cells near the ad,
almost all the atoms in your body or
recycle about every decade or so.
So there is no defined physical self of
you.
You know that theses ship,
you replace all the wood and the ship,
we still call it.
It's the pattern structure.
That was Schrodinger's term,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
okay,
so it's the pattern of information that
is your memories,
your memory cells,
memory cells.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
That's better.
But at what age?
You know,
because I have memories now that I
didn't have when I was 30 so what
happens if I'm resurrected at age 30
where's all the memories of my last,
I'm 63 now.
The last 33 years of memories of that.
I want those too.
And so just okay,
you can have all those memories,
but wait,
the memories I have now at 63 of when I
was 30 are very different than the
memories when I was 30 of of what I was
like at that time.
And so there's no fixed set of memories
even that represents you.
Cause those are constantly edited and
changed and reinterpret it.
And it's like,
okay,
now I understand.
When I had that 10 years as a bike racer
in the 1980s I,
you know,
I was just sort of going through doing
my thing and now I see in context what
that meant for my life.
But I didn't know it at the time.
That's true for everything we do.
That's why I always laugh when people
write memoirs in their twenties or
thirties.
It's like how can you write a memoir?
You don't have no idea what you're doing
going now is going to meet in 30 years.
And so in religious,
so both,
both scientific attempts at immortality
mortality or the afterlife or whatever,
and religious,
they have the same problem.
Uh,
you know,
what is up there that's being
resurrected because there is no fixed
self.
It's a constantly dynamic changing
system.
And then there's one more problem that I
deal with the point of view self,
the Pov cells,
you know,
there's uni looking out through your
eyes and you Jordan go to sleep tonight.
You wake up tomorrow morning and you're
groggy for a few minutes but,
but your,
your point of view returns and you know
the,
the singularity people,
they think,
well,
we'll copy all your memories and put
them in a computer and it will turn it
on and you'll wake up and you'll,
you'll be looking out through the little
camera hold.
They're like Johnny Depp in
transcendence and you'll be in there.
No,
I don't think so.
Why would your point of view all of a
sudden leap from your current body into
the computer in the same sense that
instead of sacrificing your brain and
slicing it up and scanning,
this is the current thoughts scanning
every sinaps.
What if in a hundred years from now we
had a sophisticated Fmr I machine that
could scan your brain and scan every
single synapse and reproduce it.
We had a computer big enough,
Moore's law doubling and so on.
It would be enough to just to reproduce
your entire connectome and turned it up,
but you're you Jordan Peterson,
he's still standing there right next to
the computer and they turn it on.
You're not all of a sudden
the absolute,
well,
there's other problems with that too,
is that,
you know,
if I remember correctly,
you
have more neurons in your autonomic
nervous system then you have in your
central nervous system.
Well,
what are you going to do about this man?
And that isn't in your head,
not just your brain.
So you have an extended buddy,
so you ionics people,
they love up the head.
We're just going to clone your butt.
Okay,
this is getting too complex,
but they really need the whole body.
Yes.
Well that's again,
that's the physical resurrection issue
is that the idea that,
and I think that you put your finger on
the floor in the,
in the,
in the new immortelle,
in the new immortality crowd.
You know,
they think they really are [inaudible]
and they think of your consciousness is
something that's,
well,
they're confused about it in some sense
because they think of it as a kind of
soul,
which would be a pattern.
And that pattern is only instantiated in
the brain.
It's like,
well,
physiologically that's just not the
case.
It's like what about the hormones?
What about like there's a look,
there's a lot of things going on in the
brain that aren't easily reducible to
synaptic patterns,
especially when you consider also its
connection with the body and you have to
consider that.